for a long time our political class has
been infected by corrupt crony
yep establishment they've sold us out to
major
international interests corporations
offshore money
and now it's really difficult to figure
out how to solve the problem
well i do believe trump is trying yep i
don't i don't i don't i
look i i do think he's an outsider i
think he you know
again i can say it a million times
character defects but you look at the
guy
and he's very clearly not part of
whatever it is these people
were doing no and and he he has a degree
in economics like
there he he can see the the money side
that's leaving america that's making us
weaker
slowly but surely but it's happening
it's not even about that i mean it is
about that right
yes my point is specifically in trump's
mind
he wants america to be the best in the
mind of our establishment political
class
yeah they want to make money at the
expense of literally anybody
anything anything yep and so trump has
been
uh essentially purging the republican
party so you had this these two big
populists you had bernie trump
trump won yup he wasn't supposed to win
but he did
trump was able to shut down the
establishment on the republican side
and win and then we saw a wave of
republicans retiring
these establishment dudes were backing
away yeah and that was a vulnerability
for the for the right-wing populist
because
it opened up the door for democrats to
try and take some of these seats but now
we're starting to see
more populist legit republicans people
like sean parnell
first of all exactly seems like a legit
dude and
on the left you're seeing a lot of
progressive grassroots style
democrats were trying to like primary
their opponents well i certainly
disagree with their politics
but there's there's a part of me that
i'm very much like
crooked crooked corrupt class that's
extracting all of our resources and
giving it to a foreign country
idealistic and kind of crazy
activist they're both really bad and i
wouldn't choose either of them if i had
to
if i had a choice yeah but i think the
crony corrupt class
has exploited us and extracted our
nation and we got to get rid of it
i'm all in favor of like can we just
vote out every incumbent period that
would be wonderful
at and at this point now i really don't
mean every
maybe 10 years ago i was like get rid of
him but you know
i like ron paul when he was when he was
in office
i disagree with a lot a lot of what ron
paul says
but he was a very very libertarian dr no
you know he's like no don't do it no
and same thing is true with rand paul
rand paul recently wrote an op-ed about
demilitarizing the police
right i actually disagree with how he's
framed things but i agree with
i agree with him more than i disagree
with him okay but like to look at what's
going on in portland
and say oh no it's so evil we must we
must defund this i'm like
well hold on hold on riot control and
defense of a courthouse
in my opinion is not like secret police
black bagging people
in the middle of night and renditioning
them offshore agreed i do believe
demilitarizing the police i agree
what does that really mean though right
you know so he's talked about how
they're getting
you know it's basically what happens is
you actually have military attack being
handed me down to local departments
and i think i don't necessarily think
that we need to just get rid of all of
the stuff they have
we definitely don't need to keep giving
them tank like apc
style you know like and something you
know uh vehicles
but we've got great local defense no
one's ever going to invade this country
that's a good point so the issue is less
so that they have it and more so the
constraints and the oversight
so there's look as as the cast escalates
in portland i imagine what would happen
if the feds didn't have the right
control stuff they did have
would the building just be burnt down
and we'd go no no
you know build it again yeah and all the
court documents that were in there would
be
lost court cases evidence people's work
people's computers emails correspondence
just like
destroyed precisely so i look it's a
tough question but anyway
more to the point when it comes to the
political class i i'd like
i i think rand paul's great i think matt
gates is pretty good i like tulsi but
tulsi is basically
retiring anyway and then you've got now
uh potentially sean parnell could win
and take a seat from a democrat we'll
see what happens there i also want to
give a shout out to uh billy prempe
oh that's right of new jersey he's got
he's got a wonderful platform then i and
i 100 agree with him isn't he for like
pot legalization
yeah i think that sounds like i mean but
he's a republican that has a lot of
good ideas and he's a younger man and
that's what we need we need a newer
younger generation getting involved in
for the future he's in north jersey i
think
yeah i think i think so yeah yeah yeah
yeah because i i remember we were
talking about him
district billy prempe uh the ninth ninth
congressional district yeah you guys
should check him out and sean parnell
yeah
uh full disclosure i've donated to sean
parnell and billy prempe because
you mentioned that and the the reason
for that is to be honest i donated to
way more democrats than republicans yeah
and i was thinking about it and i was
like at this point i think it would be
fair if you know if i think these people
for anti-war reasons were worth
supporting
that's not very fensitter of me to not
find someone i might think is going to
do a good job
on the republican side and even to this
day i've given more to democrats
so but i i do think those guys are both
you know pretty rad
so that's what we need yep we need to
get rid of we need to get rid of these
people who got in the office hoping to
get a lobbyist job
50 years ago um that's totally that look
you know what you know you know i'll
tell you if you've figured out
how to become worth 100 million dollars
off a hundred and seventy four thousand
dollars a year
wow you know that's that's amazing and
trump became a billionaire off a million
dollars
yeah congratulations to those people in
in congress who took a six-figure salary
and became worth
millions of dollars i wonder how they
did that huh while they're still
in congress too don't even get me
started on that dude it is so busted
absolutely do you see that i sent you uh
i sent uh adam the dylan radigan rant
did you watch that i did yeah dylan
radigan in
20th was it 20 2013. that was when the
video was published i wonder if that's
when the video was actually
first oh yeah that's a good point the
video was from 2013 i don't know when it
is
actually from most most of you might be
aware of the of the famous
dylan radigan ran on msnbc where he rips
apart democrats
and republicans it's eye-opening
actually he says he's
he's he's super angry and this is almost
a decade ago and he's like they are
extracting
our nation through banking through trade
through politics yep and he said it and
that
the entire time i was watching it and
especially at the end of it
i i hit you know it came to an end and i
was just like
yeah i trade was it i want trump to be
president again for another four years
i'm dead serious and i don't want him to
be encumbered by by
something that isn't true like the whole
russiagate thing you know he he
is an economist he went to school he has
a degree in economics
you know it's like sure okay all of his
businesses didn't
weren't fully successful but he had so
many businesses
and throughout that if you look at his
business history and you look through
the 90s
like that's when he kind of had a rough
patch and he figured it out and he
turned it around
i've got the uh the we need we need that
kind of leadership right now
i'll tell you my view biden is awful
100 percent agree with he's he would
voting for biden is restoring
the establishment crony crony class we
got we got biden here with us wait a
minute
listen here fat let me tell you face
pony soldier
thank you yeah here's the deal all right
what was i saying uh
if you listen the thing if you think you
know
go if you vote for biden you are trying
to restore
the crony class that was extracting our
country yeah hurting people
yep exactly if you vote for trump you're
getting a
rather imperfect man who i believe does
love this country and wants to try and
fix it there's no doubt in my mind that
he loves this country
i know his history his his parents or
his mother was an
immigrant she immigrated here from from
scotland and she
she had nothing and his grandfather came
here with nothing and they both built
businesses
and this is where he's at now here's
what i want i want something better than
trump
right right now considering what we're
looking at with biden
i'm kind of like oof you know i think
i'm gonna have to vote for trump
but i also want more than just the
president i want congress and the senate
and i don't care what party it is i want
the problem right now
is that the young excited individuals on
the democrat side are like marxists
you're right and i don't mean that in
the in the pejorative like you're a
marxist you're coming i mean like
many of them are literal marxists and in
the true sense of
the word many of them are democratic
socialists members of members of the
democratic socialists
true communism tim well arguably
but many of them are dsa many of them
are socialist
or democratic socials basically the same
thing and i don't want that none of
those people want to do
work for a living they just want to be
handed stuff that's all i'm seeing
every single one of them they just don't
want to do the work that is required to
to be successful in this country this
country allows you to do whatever you
want to do but you got to work for it
i don't want to work for it i think
these people have some kind of
broken world view and i think it's due
to
its its society in general's fault now
we can go back and analyze
how this generation came to think the
things they do i don't know if it's a
political party's fault but i will tell
you this
telling a bunch of young people to wake
up go to school every day
come home then go to high school and
then take out huge loans to go to
college
was a huge mistake to be in debt for
exactly
half of your life so i'll tell you what
your entire life is this is why i'm in
favor of some kind of loan forgiveness
okay because the reason many of these
these young people don't believe in hard
work
is because no matter how hard they work
they can't break that
that chain right they were listen man
i'll tell you a story about how much i
hate college
when i was uh in high school like high
school age i didn't
go to high school i was told go to
college you have to go to college
take out loans if you have to i read an
article from an economist who said it's
the stupidest investment possible what
person in their right mind would invest
forty thousand dollars for four years
only to be in debt forty thousand
dollars plus interest
plus interest you tell that to any
investor and they're gonna laugh at you
and say no i want a positive return year
over year yeah exactly so i said
i won't do it and it was the right move
i'm unencumbered
but i know a lot of people who were told
you have to
i know people who are like i don't want
to but i have to my parents are making
me and i'm like dude you're 18. you're
an adult
you leave and they were like you
understand they'll kick me out or
something like that i have nowhere to go
so now they go to school
they rack up debt they work really
really hard they get out they can't find
work
and in their mind hard work has never
worked for me
that's a good point and so they've been
indoctrinated their whole lives to
believe
hard work doesn't work where i was the
opposite i didn't i dropped out and i
said i'm not going to go
i'm just going to figure it out and work
hard until i get it done and here i am
yep they are trapped in this cycle where
they're still to this day
and in their mid-30s trapped in debt
they can't pay off that's a good point
so you know what they do
they say f the system give me the commie
the person who's going to forgive all of
my debt and break the chain
i will vote for them so my my opinion is
we need to break the chain which means i
would like to see
some kind of student loan forgiveness
that would freeze interest rate like
like
like uh suspend interest rates yeah you
got to pay back the principal
but the so what's happening to a lot of
these people is you take out 40 000 in
debt
you end up paying like 60 000 over more
than that probably more yeah like a lot
more
because you get deferments you got
covered people can't work they're
unemployed
here's what we're going to do we're
going to get rid of all the interest
you got to pay back what you spent well
banks are going to be like well we're
not going to give anyone
anything good we're not going to make
anything good excellent i agree
no more get ready listen if you can't
afford to go to college you don't go to
college good point
what what what world is this i never
understood this where it's like
buy things you can't afford that's
that's what they're saying that's true
that there is an absolute problem in
this country i guess you're absolutely
right
because of these guaranteed student
loans tuition is being
is skyrocketing yeah to ridiculous
numbers
so how about we figure out how to get
young people
off that that chain where they can't pay
off this debt because they can't make
enough and it just keeps accruing
and then for the future we say you're
not guaranteed alone
nope sorry then these schools are going
to be like
we're losing students what do we do
we've got to lower your tuition rates
yes and then people can start working
to pay off we also need to foster a
culture of
when people are young to to build
hobbies to get involved look when i was
when i when i was a little kid i built a
computer when i was eight
i started doing uh um just messing
around the computer
programs yeah going online i started
doing
uh game programming with like flash and
stuff when i was probably 12. well
that's
it though right there you just said it
that's that's the new hobby
it's games so when i was a little kid i
was having fun making my own platformer
game
right i made this game where you played
a dude where the whole game was trying
to make it through a factory
that was producing these little these
little monsters that would like try and
bite you
i seriously just would spend days like
coding and programming and once you get
the base programming with a program like
flash it's really easy to just drag and
drop and build it well tim
not everyone wants to learn how to code
yes yes my point though is it was really
easy for me
to be like why go to school yeah i can
find something and become good at it
so when i started you know working on
flash and stuff like that
i figured it out i reverse engineered
other you know files to figure out what
made what work and i just did it on my
own
well and and that's actually the key
what do we have right here we have this
this amazing thing called the internet
if i want to learn anything
i've been doing all this research i'm
not going to college to learn how
politics or law i'm reading the actual
laws
and i'm i'm seeing what what they're
actually doing and i'm learning from
just
reading and researching myself well i'm
not paying anyone for that
i'm getting paid for that that's that's
the best way to do it let's
let's let's be realistic about what
college is doing right now today
an 18 year old is told you have to go to
college to succeed
and they say okay what do i do take out
forty thousand dollars in debt and go to
school and they go okay
then they go to school and their
teachers keep telling them that
communism is the light
is the truth and the way yeah and they
start saying wow that's interesting
then they leave college with massive
debt they can't pay off and they
they think why can't i do this maybe my
teachers were right
communism is the way mm-hmm and they
vote for communists yep
and then that basically just destroys
everything look man it's our own fault
and we're seeing it right now that's my
my my my theory based on this
because based on what my family members
told me
is is very simple when i was told
that in the boomer generation okay not
everybody went to college you didn't
have to
because the greatest generation had high
school diplomas got jobs and were able
to feed and support their families
so their kids grow up and some of them
go to college and most of them don't
but the ones that went to college by
choice ended up making substantially
more money
okay the boomer generation then started
to believe the reason they made more
money is because they went to college
period right the reality was if you
don't have to go to college to succeed
but people chose to it meant they were
passionate about what they were chasing
here that's it right there if you're
passionate about it exactly you want to
learn about it
and then you you your passion doesn't go
away
after you get out of college you then
get a job that you're passionate about
working hard developing technology and
making a lot of money
yeah so if you if you if you were told
you don't have to go to college to
succeed
and everyone got jobs and they were
doing well then they noticed some people
were doing really well
and what did they see oh they went to
college
that's what got them extra money so they
tell their kids go to college you'll
make extra money
no be passionate about a trade a skill a
hobby
and you will make extra money okay so
this reminds me of something and i'm
just going to interject here
but when they were figuring out that
self-esteem was what kids really needed
they were looking at kids who had high
self-esteem who then went on to succeed
and they said kids need to be told that
they should have high
self-esteem because this will help them
succeed when in reality it was exactly
like it is with college
the fact of the matter was that if you
were already in possession of high
self-esteem you were going to do better
in any case
telling kids that they needed to have
high self-esteem wasn't actually going
to help them
so i see like a kind of an echo there
like earlier on when kids are younger
you know kids need they need a good
strong father
yes but i also think stories help i i
really do believe
realistic stories no necessarily i don't
know
like i think stories are part of the
problem we've been talking about how
movies
always show this this negative entity
that always exists
in every single story for a story to be
something worthwhile
there's a negative entity that you is
always present so it almost convinces
everybody
that that's the way life is i think i
think no with what lydia was just saying
that confidence comes from having a
solid family
that that gives you like look i love you
child
you you have the vin you have the
vindication you you have
confirmation that you are loved you that
and they have that
and you get that from a solid family
like i got that i know i'm loved i don't
need anyone else
that i that i need love i don't need to
convince anyone either because i know it
and that's part of confidence we need
heroes sure
yeah definitely we need heroes if you
just tell a kid all the time they're the
best
believe in yourself well then you get
arrogance and ego
and even when they're bad they'll just
convince themselves they're good okay
what what peop what people need is to
understand if at first you don't succeed
try try again
they need to understand that someone
will always be better than you no matter
what you're doing
it's a fact like skateboarding is such a
great life-building
culture competition that's the reason
why we are
in space right now the reason we are
have gotten
as far as we've gotten there are things
i can do on a skateboard
as a 34 year old like well past
my skateboarding prime that some of the
best pros in the world cannot do
yeah it doesn't mean i'm better than
them but at the top level of
skateboarding
they don't even think they're the best
they're like oh but so-and-so is way
better because they look at the other
things
the point is you want to strive to be
better than yourself
you want to every day do better than you
did than you were doing before yes
but the reason is their own antagonist
the thing i bring up with stories was
not
about heroes and villains it was about
literal heroes okay
it was about being told these lessons
like i'll defer to static shock
one like a really awesome show i watched
when i was a kid yeah it had diversity
in it but it was about this kid who
got super powers and then fought every
day to do the right thing
and to be better and to be a hero and
you wanna you wanna you wanna be
inspired look
if we told if we told stories that the
hero was the guy who went around burning
down buildings and smashing windows
and demanding communism he's going to
look for that
to get you know like social acceptance
to feel like he's part of you know
the uh you know what he's doing right we
want kids to believe that
helping build a great society planting
trees
whose shade they know they will never
sit in these are the things that make
you
heroic helping people helping provide
for them
striving to be better than yourself so
i've often thought about this in terms
of like raising kids how do you make
sure that the kid doesn't become an
arrogant
or or like just becomes someone who
thinks they're entitled to it because
they're the best
it's not so simple to just tell them to
think they're better to it's it's it's a
combination of factors to to craft that
into a young person
that's true that's why i think heroes
play a role in this and it could be a
real hero a
person you read their story of like you
know
someone who fought really hard to
finally be the first to do something
maybe they weren't allowed maybe no one
had done it before
no one believed in them i love these
stories where you have someone who
everyone like
mocks and belittles and makes fun of and
then all of a sudden they're a
billionaire who like built the biggest
company
you know there's a lot of tech pros that
are like this yeah they were the losers
in school and now they're super rich
it was all spite you know now i'm not
saying the spite is a good thing
i'm saying we just have these stories
that we should look up to people who
overcame adversity and fought every day
to be better
to build succeed and that's we want to
craft into people
college does not do that you're def
you're definitely right
absolutely not i can't believe man what
we see from
some of these kids what they believe
with school i'm gonna graduate and i'm
gonna make all this money and then they
get out and they can't even find a job
so what do they do i guess i'll vote
bernie because he's gonna pay my bills
that's why when you see like elizabeth
warren and bernie sanders saying
straight up like we're gonna pay your
bills if you vote for us
i'm like well of course they'll vote for
you if you try that yeah unfortunately
young people don't vote
maybe maybe it's it's it's it's better
that young naive people who just want
for themselves
aren't voting they're free to if they
choose to yeah
but it's no surprise to me that it's
mostly older people that vote it's
always been that way
yeah and even still it's not like every
every younger
generation feels that way because that's
not true i mean i see i see
plenty of younger generations that are
conservative it's there
there's conservatives across all totally
you know age groups
so you know we see it i think most
people
in general are just uninitiated like the
biggest the biggest
political party is didn't vote that was
me until
about six months ago in 2016. started
the show
and now i'm very political now but you
voted
right for the first time and only time
yeah me too right
and then 2012 i felt betrayed and i was
like i'm not voting for this guy i can't
get out of here yeah i'm not going to
vote for mitt romney
and then 26 came 2016 came around and i
thought the exact same thing i'm not
voting for donald trump yeah
hillary clinton irl podcast we do the
show live
monday through friday at 8pm if you want
to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you